we are ended with Ray Robson Ray I have
to start with this question yesterday's
game he came with this incredible
preparation very deep line of the
Catalan and this H4 move that made you
Ponder your options how did you feel at
that point
yeah I mean obviously I was not
expecting that line at all but I guess I
knew it a little bit not too deeply but
I knew some maybe General ideas but yeah
H4 I wasn't really sure I thought
probably his idea is to play H5 next but
apparently it's just like uh I guess a
useful waiting move which was kind of
hard for me to figure out over the board
um but I think I reacted okay oh you
reacted almost the best it seemed like
right and at some point maybe you even
were taking over did you feel like that
yeah I mean the sign is is a kind of
risky for white also like why it's
definitely risking to get worse in some
positions
um probably I had some chances for
Advantage
but it is difficult to play I really
during the game I felt like E5 is
probably the strongest I had a strong
feeling but
I couldn't quite convince myself and
I've been attending C5 the whole time
so I spent a long time there but I went
with C5 which is still okay but after
that kind of he equalized tell us the
story of today's game you came with the
white pieces it didn't feel like you
chose a very combative line would you
frame it that way no I definitely didn't
I guess I chose probably the most solid
way to play
um yeah just I guess strategy and also
based on how I was feeling
um I think also in the past I've I've
lost a lot of games to White against
Fabi so I just felt like playing Saul
today and well you know we'll probably
have a lot more fights in the playoffs
how do you assess your chances in the
playoffs as the time control gets
shorter
oh oh well he's still the favorite but
um
I think I I do believe in myself so I
think if I
play well I think I'm playing fine so I
think I'm gonna have some chances I hope
so but uh yeah I think it's gonna be
tough match hopefully very close one and
yeah this year they added the
possibility of Blitz before Armageddon
so it could also be a very long match I
guess we'll we'll have to find out but
it is going to be difficult if we do go
to Blitz I think just all this
transitioning between time controls
it's probably going to be difficult for
both of us I assume have you done any
specific training
to transition quickly from time time
formats well I I just played in Berlin
which was a blitz tournament it was
called Armageddon
um so I guess I was playing some Blitz
recently it was three plus two so same
time control that we could play here but
nowadays there's so many different
tournaments also online which are either
Rapid or Blitz that a lot of the top
players play in so I guess everyone is
kind of used to playing those time
controls regularly nowadays
um I think I'm still not that
experienced especially
maybe in Rapid I feel like I'm maybe the
least experienced comparing between
classical and and Blitz and Rapid
um but obviously I played in the
protesting several years um
some trading games so I mean I have I
have enough experience there too Ray's
still a big match a long match but
potentially ahead of yourself will let
you uh go get some rest and we'll see
you later quick quick question for you
Ray because uh Jovi's uh I know you're
Pat you're fabulous at uh puzzle rush
and I think you actually just won a
puzzle Rush Championship as well but she
said and I quote that you do eight hours
of training uh with puzzle Rush is that
true
eight hours of puzzle per day per day
um definitely not recently I'm sure I I
could like I've probably played more
than anyone in the world
um
and yeah I mean I guess when I was
really like
playing a lot trying to like break
records and stuff I was basically
playing all day so I'm sure I did
um yeah nowadays I definitely don't play
eight hours a day
um and I do
try to cut back even more I think I
don't think it's necessarily actually I
think it could be harmful
um not just because of the time
spent not focusing on regular chests but
also you just get used to only looking
for certain patterns you're not really
using your brain that much to like think
more broadly about Chess so
um yeah I'm not doing any puzzle Rush
during the tournament or anything all
right very good luck to you in the
playoffs thank you Rick